υπαροχές αδιακρίτος οι μικρές μικρές παροχές χωρίςις συνολικών πλαίσειν τα οποία αυτάζητήματα δημιουργούν αρκετά προβλήματα
σε αρκετούς τομίς παρευφερές θεμα μαζί με ττο είναι οη μεγάλες υνεργείες δεν υπάρχουν μεγάλες
συνεργειες βλέπουμε συνεχώς να γίνονται μικρά μικρά πράγματα τα οποία ποολλά κατηγορείδι οη κυβέρνηση ότι
είναι και συνέχεια των προηγούμένο ότι το αραρεύ και φαρμόζούμε το ραεύκαι αλλάψουμε και κάτι
τοαραυι πά παρακάτω και βλέπω να μην υπάρχει μια παραγωγή ενώ συνολικού πλάνου να το
οποίο να καταλίξει διλαδή να καταλήξει στοστον κόο που εν το προλέμα οικονομία πακαλά φαίνεται
και τορόρτυ άρα του του άμύπροκτές οικονομία παρα καλά αλλά λέει κάτι το μεαστο οίο
βρέται να ψεγάδνκάμε αντιπολύτσυνετακμε όλαδας ναι πι υπάρχουν θέματα αλλά αλλά δενίνδεν δεν είναι αυτό
που θα πότώρα εγώ βλεπόν μπροστά καιη ουσία είναι είναι η επόμενη μέρα οιπροηγούμε αλλά
μίλλεμε και υπερβολές το αποτέλεσμ που βλέπουμε στοτοριπόρτο άμευτο λέ ξεκάθαρά το ίδιο το άμε
είναι η προσέλκηση που έγινε λόγο συγκριών α λόγ συγκυριών τις οκρατου κρανικού προβλήματος προσερκηση
που έγινε έφερε να αυτή ται ανάπτυξε κι ατι δι ότι γνωρίζουμε όλοι ότι έχουμε
πλεόνασμα επειδή χρησιμοποιούμε τα χρήματα των τα μειο κοινωνικός α σφαλήσεω τις γεννικής κυβένεις δηλαδή
στην κεντρική κυβέρνηση πολύ απλώνκαι και ότι θέτε θέα τοτι συμβαίνι έχουμε νέλλι μα στην
κετρική κυβέρνηση αι πλεώνας νάδησμα κι πο τυν προγουμένοι κυυβέρμε μα το κίδιο έγνε το
μεγαλύτερο χικες εξς